festnahme nach über 100 rechtsextremen
drohschreiben ein 53 jähriger soll die
todesdrohungen und schnee mails
verschickt haben mehr freiheiten für
corona geimpfte kontakt beschränkungen
und ausgangssperren sollen für sie schon
ab samstag nicht mehr gelten dass es der
plan der bundesregierung
tödliches u-bahn-unglück in mexiko
mindestens 23 menschen sterben als eine
metro brücke unter dem zug zusammen
bericht
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber in einen guten abend
und willkommen bei uns kristin otto ist
auch mit dabei für den sport mache ja
mit fußball in allen facetten genannt
zweieinhalb jahre ermittlungen jetzt
meldet die polizei einen
ermittlungserfolg in einem verstörenden
fall ein 53 jahre alter mann ist in
berlin festgenommen worden er steht in
dringendem verdacht eine serie von
drohschreiben mit volksverhetzenden und
beleidigenden inhalten verschickt zu
haben unterschrieben mit direktem bezug
auf eine rechtsextremistische
terrorzelle
es beginnt im august 2008 10 die
frankfurter anwältin anwältin senna
bahar yildiz bekommt eine morddrohung
sie hatte im münchner nsu prozess eine
der opferfamilien vertreten
danach registrierte die polizei
insgesamt 115 briefe e mails und faxe
absender ein sogenannter nsu 2.0
die adressaten kommen vor allem aus
politik kunst und dem journalismus auch
nach der festnahme des verdächtigen
bleiben noch viele fragen dieser welt de
la vega in diesem berliner wohnhaus
wurde er festgenommen
alexander mutmaßlich autor von über 100
droh mails zum beispiel dieser heil
hitler ihr scheiß aktivistinnen wir
legen euch alle um unterschrieben mit
nsu 2.0 seit 2008 10 trafen diese mails
vor allem frauen aus politik und medien
sie fühlten sich bedroht weil der täter
auch immer wieder reagiert hat auf dinge
die ich besser und immer wieder klar
gemacht hat dass er beobachtet wie ich
mich bewege was ich tue
die e mails kamen immer nachts und in
manchen phasen guckt man dann eben
morgen aufs handy und mit der
befürchtung dass wieder einem ortung
gekommen ist die festnahme des 53
jährigen arbeitslosen und vorbestraften
berliners sei ein großer fahndungserfolg
der tatverdächtige ist wie
zwischenzeitlich immer wieder gemutmaßt
wurde kein hessischer polizist und hat
der hessischen polizei nie angehört
die war unter schwerem verdacht geraten
weil es von hessischen polizei computern
aus mehrere anfragen zu den persönlichen
daten der opfer gegeben hatte dass der
zusammenhang von droh mails und polizei
jetzt vom tisch sei sieht die opposition
nicht das zeige das beispiel der
bedrohten anwältin beispiel dieses spiel
auch erinnern daran dass 2018 im august
eineinhalb stunden nachdem die
datenabfrage im ersten frankfurter
polizeirevier von der familie von frau
basis der stadt fand dann das
drohschreiben bei ihr eingehen also es
besteht ein zusammenhang
und der muss aufgeklärt werden ob es
diese verbindung tatsächlich gibt und ob
es sich überhaupt um einen einzeltäter
handelt weil das muss noch geklärt
werden
es gibt in deutschland zitat klare
verrohung tendenzen so beschreibt
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer die
neueste statistik über politisch
motivierte straftaten deren zahl war im
vergangenen jahr so hoch wie noch nie
seit sie erfasst wird noch mal höher als
2016 mit den damals heftigen
diskussionen über die flüchtlingspolitik
der innenminister sagt die größte
bedrohung sei der rechtsextremismus
thomas reichert jetzt mit mehr
die zahlen die der bundesinnenminister
diesem morgen mitbringt zeigen ein
aufgewühltes land politisch motivierte
straftaten hätten einen beunruhigenden
höchststand erreicht so seehofer
beunruhigend auch weil die politische
gewalt kriminalität deutlich zunimmt
es gibt klare führung tendenzen in
unserem lande rechtsextremistische
anschläge wie in hanau im februar 2020
sind für sich verteilen einer blutspur
sie zeigten dass vom rechtsextremismus
die größte bedrohung ausgehen
insgesamt lag die zahl rechter
straftaten bei 23 1604 eine zunahme um
über fünf prozent
opfer verbände die rechte straftaten
selbst erfassen gehen davon aus dass die
zahlen sogar noch höher legen die
mangelnde staatliche erfassung rechter
gewalt setzt sich auch in 2020 vor
wir können bereits jetzt aus den
veröffentlichten pmk rechts gewalt
zahlen der länder ablesen dass viele
rechte und rassistisch motivierte taten
nicht als solcher erfasst werden wurden
gestiegen ist auch die zahl linker
straftaten wie bei ausschreitungen am
ersten mai 10 1971 fälle ein anstieg um
gut 11 prozent bei anti coroner demos
der sogenannten querdenker fällt dagegen
die zuordnung als rechte oder linke
straftaten oft schwer
am stärksten zugenommen hat mit über 19
prozent die hasskriminalität besonders
im netz wo die aufklärung schwierig ist
und wenn wir die verfolgen können
und das hat eben auch was mit der
vorratsdatenspeicherung zu tun dann
haben wir einen höheren aufklärungs
effekt seehofer will deshalb mehr
überwachung bringt nun schärfere gesetze
für bundespolizei verfassungsschutz in
den bundestag
zum ärger der opposition die darin ein
angriff auf bürgerrechte sieht
und jetzt unser nächstes großes thema
heute abend die korona lage da zeigt
sich ein positiver trend der sich zu
stabilisieren scheint immer weniger
menschen infizieren sich mit dem virus
ärzte sagen dass lage direkt am
fortschritt beim impfen
die zahlen im detail jetzt von jan
fischer bei den impfungen geht es weiter
voran
und zwar deutlich mittlerweile haben
mehr als 23,8 millionen menschen ihre
erste spritze bekommen
das entspricht 28,7 prozent der
bevölkerung mehr als 6,7 millionen sind
sogar vollständig geimpft 8,1 prozent
gleichzeitig scheint die dritte welle
abzuflauen das rk ii meldet aktuell
etwas mehr als 7500 neuinfektionen das
sind 3442 weniger als vor einer woche
auch der trend bei der sieben tage
incidents ist positiv lag der wert vor
einer woche noch bei rund 167 liegt er
nun bei 141,4 doch von region zu region
gibt es deutliche unterschiede während
teile von thüringen und sachsen
dunkelrot sind verzeichnen vor allem die
nördlichen bundesländer niedrige
inzidenz aber nicht nur dort gibt es
lichtblicke
bundesweit geht jetzt sogar jede vierte
region unter der schwelle von 100 und
damit unter dem grenzwert der bund ist
notbremse angesichts besserer zahlen bei
den instanzen kündigen bayern und
niedersachsen jetzt konkrete
erleichterungen an für außengastronomie
und tourismus zu pfingsten sollen hotels
und campingplätze dort öffnen wo die
inzidenz stabil unter 100 liegt an
seinem stern berichtet nach ganz vielen
grauen monaten voller virus sorgen heute
mal eine gute nachricht etwa in diesem
hotel in grainau landkreis
garmisch-partenkirchen ab dem 21
mai dürfen sie hier wieder aufmachen
sollte die inzidenz bei den
neuansteckungen unter 100 bleiben
wir freuen uns natürlich dass man jetzt
aufsperren dürfen ist jetzt recht
schneller termin der auf uns zukäme ist
aber auch dass wärme schaffen die
schwierigkeiten seiner zeit mitarbeiter
finden ein mitarbeiter einstellen
urlaub im hotel außengastronomie öffnen
alles mit hygiene und test konzepten und
nur dann wenn die inzidenz tten
mitspielen in den städten und
landkreisen bayern ist nicht nur ein
tourismusland aber es ist für die
menschen glaube ich auch psychologisch
und seelisch wichtig an dass wir eine
perspektive haben und ich denke das
konzept jetzt ist eine gute mischung aus
vorsicht und optimismus
eine ganz ähnliche planung auch in
niedersachsen schon ab kommender woche
dürfte in einigen regionen eine menge
aufgemacht werden auch die hotels
zunächst aber nur für gäste aus
niedersachsen wir sind nach wie vor sehr
vorsichtig jede dieser
lockerungsmaßnahmen über die wir
sprechen sind mit 345 unterschiedlichen
sicherung versehen
insbesondere erwarten wir in ganz vielen
fällen tagesaktuelle kontrollierte
negativer tests negativ tests und ab in
den urlaub bald also möglich mancher
orts in deutschland was aber ist mit
sonne und strand im ausland vor allem
die tourismus länder in europa drängen
der griechische tourismus minister heute
auf werbetour in berlin
es ist sehr wichtig dass der tourismus
zwischen griechenland und deutschland
wieder in gang kommt das ist auch
wichtig für europa der tourismus ist ein
wichtiger teil unserer wirtschaft
wirtschaft arbeitsplätze endlich
erholung es hängt viel dran
experten warnen aber auch zuviel
lockerung könnte die virus zahlen auch
schnell wieder nach oben treiben
inzwischen ist auch klar wie es
bundesweit mit den lockerungen für
geimpfte und genesene weitergeht die
regierungskoalition hat sich bereits auf
eine verordnung geeinigt am freitag
könnte der bundesrat grünes licht geben
das heißt am samstag würde die
verordnung wohl in kraft treten
geimpfte und genesene bekämen damit
rechte zurück insbesondere müssen sie
sich dann nicht mehr an ausgangs und
kontakt beschränkungen halten und das
führt nach wie vor natürlich zu fragen
gerade auch juristischer art felix
zimmermann es bei uns aus unserer zdf
rechts redaktion guten abend felix da
ergeben sich also neue freiheiten die
frage auch neue ansprüche für geimpfte
und genießen und neue ansprüche nicht
vollständig geimpften die können jetzt
nachts raus aber kein anspruch dass die
ba auf macht sie können sich mit
unbegrenzt vielen anderen vollständig
geimpften treffen haben aber keinen
anspruch die in einem restaurant zu tun
das verfassungsrechtlich durchaus
problematisch nämlich aus sicht der
restaurantbesitzer wenn nämlich von
geimpften keine gefahr mehr ausgeht
warum sollte man nicht auch für die
öffnen dürfen
die bundesregierung will aber eben
schrittweise lockern fürchtet eine
erosion der regeln und vielleicht wohl
auch bis in den neid der ungeübten
stichwort night einiges an ärger ist
natürlich bei den ungeimpften damit
verbunden naturgemäß ist denn das jetzt
juristisch eine art
zweiklassengesellschaft die sich da
auftut gerade was grundrechte angeht
also erstmal natürlich ja und da ist der
ärger auch besonders der jüngeren
stückweit nachvollziehbar ihnen wurde ja
gesagt er soll zu hause bleiben für die
älteren und das sind jetzt die ersten
für die gelockert wird andererseits was
habe ich als ungeimpfter davon wenn die
geimpften jetzt auch zu hause bleiben
dürfen eigentlich nichts deswegen geht
aus meiner sicht jetzt nicht um
solidarität sondern eher bisschen um
neid und die vermeidung von neid ist
kein verfassungsrechtliches gut
mittelfristig wird auch da keine
zweiklassengesellschaft geben weil
erstens jahr in absehbarer zeit jetzt
nun wirklich dann ein impfangebot für
alle da ist und auch für die die nicht
impfen wollen die profitieren ja auch
denn wenn die korona zahlen durch die
vielen impfungen sinken
dann ist natürlich lockerung für alle in
kraft treten auch für die interessante
erläuterungen felix zimmermann heute
abend herzlichen dank dafür
aufmachen aber wie weit diese und
weitere fragen haben die kollegen von
zdf heute live gleich ab 19.30 an den
spd-gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
und sie können mitdiskutieren
in der zdf- heute- app und unseren
social media kanälen noch knapp vier
monate bis zur bundestagswahl mehrere
ministerien wollen die verbleibende zeit
offenbar nutzen und noch hunderte ihrer
beamten befördern und neue stellen
schaffen das meldet die bild-zeitung
kanzlerin angela merkel müsse diese
beförderungen stoppen fordert der bund
der steuerzahler
angesichts der epochalen corona krise
greife keine erklärung dafür
wie sollten sich die großen westlichen
industriestaaten gegenüber china und
russland aufstellen zwei autoritär
geführten ländern die ihren eigenen weg
gehen
das wollen die g7 außenminister klären
in london heute bei ihrem ersten
persönlichen treffen seit zwei jahren
es geht um menschenrechte aber eben auch
um gute handelsbeziehungen andreas stamm
kommen sie wirklich der blick des
gastgebers des britischen außenministers
rapssaat fast alles vier jahre trump
hatten einen grundpfeiler der westlichen
allianz das g7 forum ordentlich ins
wanken gebracht beim ersten persönlichen
treffen in der nacht ampera geht es
daher um nicht weniger als eine
wiederbelebung von wieder
gleichgesinnten so außenminister maß
hier treffen sich liberale demokratie
die sich gemeinsam gegen autoritäre
regime mal in der welt aufstellen wollen
uns verbinden die werte wie demokratie
freiheit und menschenrechte und diese
wollen wir endlich wieder gemeinsam in
der ganzen welt vertreten
vor allem gegenüber russland gegen
dessen staatlich organisierte des
informationskampagnen wollen die g7
einen mechanismus entwickeln der falsch
nachrichten schnell aufdecken und
öffentlich korrigieren könne und china
das aggressiv seinen wirtschaftlichen
und politischen einfluss ausbauen wolle
man gemeinsam grenzen aufzeigen märkte
west gegen den westen wieder großartig
machen diese werte gemeinschaft stärken
verstärken mit freunden aus australien
indien südkorea und dann gemeinsam den
autokraten dieser welt paroli bieten das
soll die botschaft dieses g7 gibt es in
london sein
wir wollen wieder wer sein auch wenn es
schwerfällt die rivalen auf der
weltbühne gestärkt die konflikte
zahlreich von syrien über ukraine bis
irans atomprogramm obendrein pandemie
und klimawandel bekämpfen
beim familienfoto macht man leichtes
unwohlsein spüren ob der last der
herausforderungen im wissen dass die g7
noch nicht wieder voll da sind
mexiko city mit mehr als 20 millionen
einwohnern eine der größten städte der
welt und so dicht besiedelt das neue
metro linien zum beispiel auch als
hochbahn auf stelzen über dem
straßenverkehr verlaufen
gestern abend ist ein teil einer solchen
trasse eingestürzt genau in dem moment
als eine bahn darüber vor mindestens 23
menschen wurden bei dem unglück getötet
70 weitere wurden verletzt sebastian
eben jetzt mit den einzelheiten
diese bilder einer überwachungskamera
zeigen den moment als die brücke nach
gibt die waggons der metrolinie 12 auf
eine straße in mexiko-stadt krachen
menschen und autos werden unter ihnen
begraben schnell versammeln sich freunde
und angehörige an der unglücksstelle
meine freundin war auf dem heimweg
sie kamen um kurz vor elf von der arbeit
aber ihre mutter und ich haben den
kontakt zu ihr verloren
sie antwortet nicht auf anrufe wir
wissen gerade nicht wo sie ist
die rettungsarbeiten gestalteten sich
kompliziert und müssen in der nacht
kurzzeitig unterbrochen werden
zu groß ist die gefahr dass die waggons
weiter abrutschen
die metro linie 12 steht im zentrum
massiver korruptionsvorwürfe
schon kurz nach ihrer eröffnung 2014
musste sie wegen struktureller mängel
für eineinhalb jahre stillgelegt werden
medienberichten zufolge wurde sie bei
dem verheerenden erdbeben 2017 ebenfalls
beschädigt aber nicht repariert
die bürgermeisterin der stadt beteuert
dass die konstruktionen erst letztes
jahr gründlich überprüft worden sein und
verspricht aufklärung
ich glaube wir sollten nicht spekulieren
deswegen wird es ein gutachten geben zum
einen von der staatsanwaltschaft zum
anderen aber auch eine externe
untersuchung
dann werden wir die wahrheit ans licht
bringen und erfahren was die gründe für
das unglück waren
der katalog des versenders ganz an der
unglücksstelle laufen jetzt die
aufräumarbeiten auf hochtouren
zurück nach deutschland ungemütlich war
dieser vierte mai heute bei uns
sturmtief eugen wütete aber weniger
heftig als befürchtet
am meisten hatte der bahnverkehr zu
kämpfen in einem ortsteil von chemnitz
krachte eine regionalbahn in einem
umgestürzten baum verletzt wurde zum
glück niemand
auch anderswo knickte der sturm vor
allem bäume um meist blieb es bei
blechschäden
und damit sind wir in dieser sendung
beim sport fast sportlich ist es nicht
so richtig über die zustände beim
deutschen fußball-bund christin kann man
eigentlich nur noch den kopf schütteln
wer weiß was noch kommt
im machtkampf an der spitze des
deutschen fußball bundes wächst nun auch
der druck auf vizepräsident rainer koch
in einem dem zdf vorliegenden schreiben
fordert ihn dfl chef christian seifert
zu einer stellungnahme auf wegen
angeblicher weitergabe falscher
informationen
es erinnert an eine schachpartie mit
immer wieder neuen überraschenden zügen
die den gegner schwer unter druck setzen
in einem schreiben das auch an die 36
profivereine und dem gesamten dfb
vorstand gerichtet ist fordert dfl chef
christian seifert den dfb
vizepräsidenten rainer koch zu einer
stellungnahme auf die offenkundigen
probleme des dysfunktionalen systems dfb
löst man nicht durch den aufbau
imaginärer feindbilder und
abenteuerlicher verschwörungstheorien
sondern durch seit langem überfällige
strukturelle und personelle reformen
fritz keller wird der erste dfb
präsident sein der sich im mai noch vor
dem sportgericht des verbandes
verantworten muss dort wird es um
kellers vergleich von koch mit einem
nazi richter gehen joachim löw kann bei
seinem letzten turnier als bundestrainer
auf mehr akteure zurückgreifen
die uefa hat entschieden die teams für
die europameisterschafts-endrunde wegen
der korona pandemie von 23 auf 26
spieler aufzustocken und
hoffnungsschimmer richtung klassenerhalt
hertha bsc ist nach zwei wochenlanger
quarantäne
mit einem 1 1 beim 1
in den bundesliga alltag zurückgekehrt
und sichert sich einen wichtigen punkt
im abstiegskampf
die hertha in blau hat nicht den besten
start trifft aber zuerst lukaku zur
führung in der 36 minute für die mainzer
die zuletzt rekordmeister bayern münchen
besiegt hatten gleicht philipp mähne
noch vor der pause aus das erste
bundesliga tor des österreichers
danach ist die härter besser die
siegchance vergibt chistoph piontek in
der 82 minute mit dem punktgewinn aber
kann berlin gut leben im drei tage
rhythmus stehen jetzt die spiele an ein
sieg am donnerstag gegen freiburg und
die hertha hätte den abstiegsplatz erst
mal verlassen
[Musik]
die letzten wochen waren eher kühl jetzt
der sturm bleibt die frage wann kommen
sonne und wärme antworten gleich von
katja hog
ich empfehle ihnen das heute journal um
21 uhr 45 die kollegin bettina schausten
hat fragen zu den rechten für geimpfte
an die bundesjustizministerin
wir sind hier morgen wieder für sie da
punkt 7 für heute auf wiedersehen und
machen sie sich alle einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das ist ein
wirklich sehr eindrucksvoller wolken
wirbel der sich in den vergangenen 24
stunden hier von großbritannien kommend
weiter bis zur nordsee geschoben hat der
wolken wirbel diese sturmtiefs folgen
der reicht von südskandinavien über
polen und mitteleuropa bis zum atlantik
und so gab es eben starke stürmische
böen ja sogar orkanböen
der brocken im harz meldete solche und
sehr stürmisch geht es jetzt auch heute
abend und in der nacht weiter und selbst
morgen früh sind an den küsten von nord-
und ostsee noch starke bis stürmische
böen möglich
es ist nicht nur sehr windig sondern
auch sehr nass in der nacht wegen des
vor allen dingen an den alpen sonst sind
in norddeutschland einige schauer
unterwegs weil der wind die luft so
richtig gut durchmischt bleibt es mild
die temperaturen sinken auf 9 grad an
der donau und 4 grad im sauerland und
nur in den westlichen mittelgebirgen
geht's auf null grad runter da droht
also am boden frost tagsüber lägen die
temperaturen kaum einer anderen werden
uns erwarten acht grad zum beispiel
nordfriesland und 13 grad am oberrhein
und morgen werden sie an den alpen und
auch an den küsten von nord- und ostsee
selten mal die sonne sehen da wird es
kräftig schütten sonst sind viele
schauer unterwegs zum teil mit blitz und
donner und sehr wechselhaft geht es dann
noch donnerstag und freitag weiter das
wochenende wird sonic the machine am 8